Philip Mudd what do you think will come
of the investigation into Trump campaign
advisor Carter page and his ties to
Russia and I might add to that what
about Michael Flynn and his ties and
everybody else's toes look the reason
Carter page is being featured is that
he's prominent in the press not because
he's the most prominent investigative
target the FBI I think there will
eventually be an indictment the FBI
director is not going to Barriss himself
by publicly telling the American people
he's open an investigation and then
especially after a Hillary debacle come
out six months later presumably this
summer this fall and say I made a
mistake not somebody's going to get
indicted I don't know if it's Carter
page at dudes chump change I think it's
somebody higher up the food chain but
don't don't you get those guys to flip
on the people high on the food chain
it's not that way you do it is you you
get Michael Flynn you say Michael you
want to go to jail you want to talk
about Donald Adam yeah a couple ways you
do it number one they've got to have a
significant amount of intercept that is
communications with the Russians that
let them doubt this path it ain't Carter
page saying I talked to it's academic in
Moscow that doesn't get you a judge to
say I can read his email it's some sort
of communication that it was suggesting
is doing something wrong and then you're
going to get as you say people are going
to flip because you're going to walk in
saying son you've got a federal charge
are you going to talk that person is
going to go home their wife and their
kids going to say I don't want three
hots and a cot in the federal pen I'll
talk so they are going to talk yeah this
is going to go forward this will go ugly
I don't know when sometime this year it
will go ugly so my prediction with John
Kasich could come true in two years he
could be a very wounded animal still you
don't understand a campaign manager is
not a critical member of the campaign I
don't know if you pick that up during
the that's a joke
what I'm talking about is clapping on
the inside no no what I'm talking about
is you remember when this started coming
out the White House starts saying Paul
Manafort is manifold Paul Manafort was
not somebody who was really critical he
was only the campaign man right so I
think we're tearing again and we've seen
this already as distancing from these
folks when the indictments come out to
say they were peripheral to the campaign
and as soon as we learned about Mike
when we fight they always try to
distance themselves I mean Nixon tried
it remember he threw John Mitchell
overboard and then Haldeman and
Ehrlichman and eventually you you run
out of people to throw off the bow of
the ship you know something okay he's
used to firing people right he's got the
discus the catch phrase Gabe do you
think you think misogyny played a role
in the media coverage of Hillary Clinton
I think without you know these are
complicated issues but I think without
question misogyny is baked into the
culture so yes it did play a role
because the media is just a reflection
of the culture and you know this sort of
dovetails and ties into the Fox News
story because for 20 years Roger Ailes
programmed Republicans to think of women
as sexualized objects and so when you
have a woman running for president that
line of attack that Trump played which
is that she's not up to the job because
she's a woman I think had political
resonance no stamina and I think
Republicans have for years tried to
feminize Democrats and we all remember
John Kerry on the windsurfer and going
back and forth yes or in the in the bike
you know there's one main reason they
were able to feminize Democrats soft on
Russia yeah so the way they are able to
just turn on and done there is no shame
in their game it is unbelievable
principles not today George on the
anniversary of killing bin Laden what is
your assessment of the US war on terror
oh yes the anniversary this yeah yeah
it's also the anniversary I think of
mission accomplished mission
accomplished the like toys for my
anniversary yes I think we are in danger
of reigniting the global war on terror
by sheer rhetorical bumbling
Obama tried to keep it in a manageable
place where we don't let down our guard
but we don't turn this into world wars
life footprint right we we try not to
create a war between the world's Muslims
in the United States I think Trump
if only the ninth circuit would let him
is trying to take steps back in that
direction yeah the fact that Michael
Flynn is gone is a major thing because
HR McMaster who I interviewed and
written about is the opposite he is not
the sort to get into that game Flynn
absolutely was he wrote a book about it
so I think the fact that Trump has no
coherent views about this and now the
guy who has a voice in his ear was HR
McMaster is probably the best thing we
have going in not getting bad news about
to make his Trump's about to make his
first overseas trip he's going to
correct it Israel
yeah Saudi Arabia and the Vatican he
said my friend my friend the Cardinals
they're very happy I'm going to that
great town Rome
going to Rome and Israel no golf court
or the eradicate but I but what what is
behind that we're going to drop in on
the world's three great faiths Judaism
Christianity and oil visiting as
properties I guess so I know I mean
that's a non trip okay will Trump's
religious liberty executive order help
placate his evangelical base I don't
know if they need placating they love
them they love them from me did you
figure this out we wouldn't love a
bright we have a guy whoever we got a
guy who C really grabs women right a guy
who makes fun of disabled people it
talks about a woman's menstrual cycle
makes fun of the face of an opposite of
an opponent Andrew evangelicals say this
is our hope for the future if you can
figure out American politics you're a
better man than I because that makes no
sense well and they didn't get yeah but
it didn't have anything to do with that
it had to do with the fact that they had
so much attention placed on abortion of
course I mean I got the guy so that's
the gay actually went through their will
I as a tool like a pawn like Trump team
yesterday they are eye on the prize in a
way the Democrats are way behind on that
that's right they Mitch McConnell knew
what he was doing when he kept that seat
open
new in the voters my job is a Supreme
Court seat open elect the guy who will
put the anti-abortion guy in there and
that's what we care about okay uh will
the hacking attack oh there was a
hacking attack right against French
candidate Emmanuel macron doom his
campaign so it looks like Putin's at it
again this time in France he's at it
again but the there's a significantly
broader gap in polling between marine
lepen and mark cone so hopefully there's
not too much in the Dakotas as a shall
we say different personal background and
most politicians to begin with yes it's
very hard to slander a guy you married
his mom didn't he she's a little bit
older but I a little I think he was
fifteen and she was thirty nine is what
I read it was true love I mean are you
again I am not in fact that makes them
unique in French politics is the fact
that he is both more of a market liberal
as well as cultural liberal which in
France is a little anathema because they
had such a strong kind of social system
that folks don't want to give up so
that's made him a little complicated for
a lot of French voters but but watch
this bill this is critical to French
peace watch next week during the
hearings and think about the hearings in
the last week or two how often do
politicians on both sides of the aisle
want to point fingers that's one
question next question that I want to
see answered that you won't get into
this shows the Russians that learn
nothing from American sanctions which we
knew what happened how often will be
there via question in the coming months
in congressional investigations about
how we protect candidates in 2018 and
2020 that's a more boring question it's
not as sexy as going after Carter page
that's the question they should be
asking they won't that's what we do here
boring not sexy all right thank you
everybody
you